[Music]
on this tuesday night the message from
afghanistan's militant group
the taliban tries to strike a new tone
after taking control of the country but
canada isn't buying it they are a
recognized terrorist organization why
the country's women and girls fear the
power grab their leadership is one thing
the foot soldiers are doing another
thing a first look at how canadians plan
to vote and will nova scotia's
provincial election set the tone for the
federal race
ontario and quebec roll out new
mandatory vaccine measures who needs the
shots to go to work plus child care and
affordability what the federal parties
have planned for parents without child
care there is no coming of this
recession
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight robin gill
another flight from afghanistan has
safely landed in canada refugees from
kabul arrived this evening at toronto's
pearson airport this is the area where
the group was processed canada has
promised to resettle 20 thousand afghan
citizens
at risk under the taliban
good evening and thank you for joining
us as afghans flee in fear the taliban
is settling in today fighters patrolled
the streets as their leaders launched a
major public relations campaign the
militant group held its first news
conference since taking kabul is trying
to convince the world it's changed
the group promised not to discriminate
against women or seek revenge against
opponents but for those who lived
through the taliban's brutal rule in the
90s there is unease and skepticism
today the canadian government made its
position on the taliban takeover clear
canada has no plans
to recognize the taliban as the
government of afghanistan they are a
recognized terrorist organization under
canadian law
justin trudeau says canada's priority is
resettling as many afghans as possible
but the reality is that many people
desperate to flee may be stuck the prime
minister says the taliban has now taken
control of some key routes to the
airport jackson proskow begins our
coverage with the situation on the
ground in kabul
in vehicles that once belonged to the
u.s backed government taliban fighters
now patrol the streets of kabul we are
assuring the safety a taliban
spokesperson vowed we will not hold
grudges using an inaugural press
conference to promise not to harm those
who worked with the u.s and its allies
also vowing to respect the rights of
women
few know what to believe explains this
26 year old university lecturer so
mentally people have been heartbroken
they they have kind of a lot of concerns
about their future about their dreams
about their life about their individual
freedoms and all the things which they
have had
from last 20 years
escape provides the only guarantee of
safety at the airport thousands of
american soldiers have arrived to
provide security to allow for the
departure of foreign citizens and the
afghans who worked with them the taliban
have informed us that they are prepared
to provide the safe passage of civilians
to the airport
after being caught so off guard by the
rapid fall of the country the u.s now
believes it has free reign to continue
evacuation flights until the end of
august we have had no hostile
interactions no attack and no threat by
the taliban but given the taliban's
reputation for brutality experts
question whether the peace will really
last though leniency may be the only
path to international legitimacy they're
going to have a very hard time getting
diplomatic recognition any kind of
economic assistance any kind of trade
opportunities in the region they'll be
at pariah state if they behave the way
they did in the late 90s rule by anyone
but the taliban is no longer an option
in the coming days the biden
administration hopes to be able to
airlift up to 9 000 people per day out
of the country
this fragile moment may be the only time
left to leave
jackson prosko global news washington
justin trudeau faced a barrage of
questions again today over the crisis in
afghanistan he's been taking heat over
refusing to clarify how canada would
view a taliban government mercedes
stephenson reports from the campaign
trail
they have taken over and replaced a duly
elected democratic government
by force
it's a much more clear and critical
position than trudeau took yesterday in
quebec where he waffled on the answer of
recognizing the taliban
royal canadian air force planes and
special operations forces personnel have
deployed to kuwait to rescue canadian
and afghan interpreters on the ground in
afghanistan yesterday mr trudeau said
the planes would land as soon as the
airfield was secured but 24 hours later
the department of national defense still
would not confirm that that had happened
planes from the united states and india
have landed scenes of desperation in
kabul have triggered calls for canada to
accept more afghan refugees just before
the election mr trudeau promised to
accept 20 000 but those spots are
actually from a pre-existing program and
reserved for afghans who have already
fled the country not those now caught
under taliban rule today the liberal
leader is promising to accept as many
afghan refugees as possible but did not
give a number the taliban need to ensure
free access to people to get to the
airport we will continue to work with
our international partners to put
pressure on them to do just that the
dire situation for canadian interpreters
on the ground remains and while they are
hopeful canadian planes will be arriving
to evacuate them they still face major
hurdles in the form of bureaucratic red
tape canadian veterans groups working
with interpreters say the forms are so
complicated many interpreters have not
been able to complete them even before
the country fell to the taliban today
the prime minister promised flexibility
communication is another issue robin
global news has been receiving texts
from former interpreters saying they
don't know when to go to the airport or
how to board those canadian planes
mercedes stephenson in barrie ontario
thanks mercedes coming up a little later
the dangerous and uncertain future
facing women and girls in afghanistan
how the taliban takeover is putting
their rights and lives at stake and the
growing calls for help
turning to the federal election campaign
today the conservatives are selling
canadians a consumer policy they hope
will win them votes it's one the party
has pitched before a break from the gst
abigail beeman is traveling with leader
aaron o'toole and abigail first of all
let's talk about the fact the leader is
meeting with voters in person
well robin as you can hear he is about
to have his first small covet safe rally
i asked the conservative leader whether
he feels he connects as well with voters
virtually as he does in person he didn't
directly answer but stressed that he's
been meeting with tens of thousands by
phone and he's focused on campaigning
safely
[Music]
aaron o'toole moved his campaign from an
empty ottawa hotel
to one in toronto he's hoping to sell
his gst holiday plan to businesses and
customers no federal tax at retail
stores throughout december without
actually meeting many of them yet you
won't have to fill out any lengthy forms
or applications to get this tax break
your five percent discount will show up
at the till at your favorite retailer he
hopes it will bring more shoppers into
brick and mortar stores battered by the
pandemic but some behind those tills say
putting the onus on business means the
return won't be worth the headache a lot
of small business owners in addition to
not being a computer
are not accountants
and
they're they're just getting by this
former senior conservative staffer says
with growing evidence cost of living is
the number one issue for voters the
policy could be a winner certainly from
the polling it seems to hit all the
right spots in terms of party support
and it's probably pretty popular in
suburban areas too where the
conservatives need to win votes
especially in ontario mixed reaction
from shoppers in downtown toronto it's
something i definitely would think about
and i think it's a great idea for the
businesses
to bring people in i think it's an
election trick you know it's just a
hollow promise
really it's in the long term it's it's a
puff in the
pan well it's no surprise o'toole's
first in-person event is in the greater
toronto area that's a long time liberal
conservative battleground in a region
he'll have to pick up more seats in if
he hopes to form government after this
the conservatives head to quebec another
important area one in which the
conservatives have an entire team
devoted to winning extra seats in that
province robin abigail beeman in
richmond hill ontario
the ndp is the first campaign to hit the
west coast the party is hoping to make
some gains in british columbia michael
couture is traveling with jug meat
seeing in a riding new democrats hope to
reclaim mike
robin this conservative riding has
flipped between the ndp and tories a
number of times over the course of the
last few elections and the new democrats
believe they can win it back after
losing it in 2019 by just 153 votes
there are several battlegrounds in bc
that leader jagmeet singh has his eye on
port moody coquitlam is just one of them
singh's pitch here is that an ndp
government would invest heavily in small
community businesses like the ppe maker
he visited tuesday a lot of the
decisions that are made by governments
are based on the will and my will is to
invest in local companies to support
canadians and in our times of need to
have the capacity to produce and
manufacture in canada with the forest
fire still raging in bc singh was also
blaming the trudeau liberals for failing
to tackle climate change and curb
emissions the ndp leader's pitch in this
province is that an ndp government is
the only one that would follow through
with progressive environmental policies
the ndp firmly believes it can win over
young progressive voters and party
insiders say they're even targeting
green mp paul manley's riding on
vancouver island
robin michael couture in coquitlam bc
thanks mike
here's how leaders strategize go into
ridings where races are tight campaign
in places where there's opportunity to
make gains it's still early days but
campaigns really do matter and elections
are all about momentum but for the
moment as eric sorensen reports not much
has changed for voters
masks and elbow bumps are different but
what if a 500 million election campaign
really changed nothing a few seats
shuffled and another liberal minority
government it's not what anyone seems to
want the party leaders all want change
here in in danforth having someone like
claire hacksall will be someone who's
going to fight for you the ndp believes
it can make inroads on the liberals by
winning back former leader jack
leighton's old riding the conservative
leader was in toronto with plans to go
to the nearby richmond hill riding which
his party lost to the liberals by just
200 votes last time everybody's going to
be going after the liberals given that
the real focus right now is on whether
it's going to be a liberal minority or
majority the big push is going to be on
those places where there are lots of
seats available but the latest ipsos
survey suggests the status quo if the
election were held now the liberals lead
at the moment is about five points over
the conservatives 36 to 31 compared with
the 2019 election results the liberals
are up three the conservatives down
about three the ndp up four what really
matters though are the number of seats
to be won at disillusioned the liberals
have 155 seats and with a little bump in
support they're within striking distance
of the majority of 170 seats but all
parties see in these numbers
opportunities to make gains it's an
incredible pleasure to be back here in
coburg to see so many people out like
the other parties the liberals aren't
playing defense they also want change to
reclaim their majority they're targeting
ridings like this eastern ontario
district they once held but lost by
three points to the conservatives in
2019. all parties are going to be
playing offense in this election because
there's
very small differences in terms of the
voting percentages overall are going to
swing seats back and forth one way or
the other
this election is going to be a game of
mentions with voter intentions so far
changing very little the parties are
identifying close races they can swing
in their favor but as they poach from
each other the outcome for now looks not
so different from the last election eric
sorensen global news toronto
there are reports an arrest warrant has
been issued for major general danny
fortan who is facing one count of sexual
assault his lawyers say he will turn
himself into police tomorrow morning
following a military investigation he
denies the allegation and has challenged
the federal government on its decision
to end his secondment to the vaccine
task force
quebec plans to make covet-19 vaccines
mandatory for care workers the mandate
will apply to people who are in contact
with patients for more than 15 minutes
at a time premier francois lagos says
his government will debate the issue
next week
we have to
take the balance of course it's
hard for the workers
but we have to protect patients
ontario is stepping up its health
measures in response to the delta
variant the province is requiring health
and education workers to get vaccinated
or take regular covid19 tests as early
as this week third shots will be offered
to vulnerable people including
transplant patients and long-term care
residents an eligibility for the pfizer
vaccine will be extended to children who
turn 12 this year
we're making progress it's just not
quick enough and i think these
immunization policies will better
protect ontarians
against the fall
and are heading in the right direction
ontario is also pausing lifting further
public health measures
a close race in nova scotia coming up
why the results in this provincial
election matter to the federal campaign
we have breaking news in nova scotia
where a liberal gamble has gone in favor
of the progressive conservatives global
news has projected a pc government in
that province it's a blow to the
provincial liberals who were trying to
get a third straight majority our ross
lord has been watching this election
ross it was supposed to be a slam dunk
what went wrong for ian rankin's liberal
party
well they did have a big lead at the
start of this campaign robin but now
that we know that the pendulum has swung
from the liberals to the pcs it is time
for the party and for others to look at
it and look at that very question what
went wrong well one thing that went
wrong was that a pair of impaired
driving incidents from ian rankin's
young adult life resurfaced and there
were questions about how he handled
expressing or fessing up to those there
were questions about the resignation of
a candidate who says essentially she was
forced to resign for reasons that a lot
of people objected to there was even
trouble with ian rankin's communication
strategy which at times excluded media
from some of his events there were
events that had happened that were only
revealed after the fact in communication
to uh to media so
there's sort of a lot of things there
to chew on it was seen that
rankin came in at the tail end
of
stephen mcneil's management of the covet
19
issue and then tried to parlay that
into a majority government
but the the pcs under tim houston and
the ndp under gary burrell hammered at
him and his government over their what
they said poor management of health care
aside from covet 19. so disjointed
ambulance service
longer waiting lists for doctors gosh
that's all the time we have for you now
because we're so much
that just crushed the liberals
still ahead child care takes the
election spotlight
the federal election will be among other
things a referendum on justin trudeau's
10 a day national child care plan before
the election call the liberals were
making campaign-style announcements on
the issue here's ann gaviola on what
early childhood experts and parents are
saying
finding child care actually was a
nightmare bridget casey is a working mom
who spends a huge chunk of her paycheck
on child care for her daughter right now
her daycare bill is over a thousand
dollars per month it's not quite as high
as my rent but it's close
because this pandemic has
disproportionately impacted working
parents especially working mothers
policy experts say a federal child care
strategy should be front and center in
this election we are not going to get
back to economic normal
while women are still back in the home
and without child care there is no
coming out this recession the liberals
remain committed to their 30 billion
plan to create a 10 a day national child
care program which seven provinces plus
the yukon have already signed on to the
ndp's platform includes a universal 10 a
day program for all parents while the
conservatives have a different strategy
a refundable tax credit program to cover
a maximum of 75 of daycare costs for
low-income families to replace the 10 a
day plan critics of the tax credit
approach question its impact there's no
benefits for families that are earning
more than 150 000 per year and that
sounds like a lot uh to many families
but that is still like a middle class
family in toronto one concern with a 10
a day plan is in its implementation big
provinces like ontario and alberta
aren't yet on board there isn't enough
in the deals that we've seen to date
which require the provinces and
territories to put in the infrastructure
the kind of infrastructure which
supports her public education system as
we approach election day some parents
want to hear a wide range of options i
would love to see federal leaders start
looking into alternatives of child care
whether that be
spouses taking
leave of absence from work where their
job is still secure according to
scotiabank research child care is the
single biggest household expenditure for
the average canadian family which means
this affordability issue could be the
biggest ballot box issue for families
too
ann gaviola global news toronto
up next fears the taliban could erase
progress made for women's rights in
afghanistan
i am deeply concerned about the
situation in afghanistan right now
especially about the safety of women and
girls there this is actually
an urgent humanitarian
crisis right now that we need to provide
our help and support
in 2012 malala yousafzai was shot by the
taliban for defending girls education in
pakistan today she says she fears for
her sisters in afghanistan the future
they were promised is slipping away and
there are fears of a return to the
taliban's ultra-conservative islamic
rule that severely restricts the
movements of women today a spokesperson
for the taliban said women will be
allowed to work and study as long as
it's within the framework of islamic law
but as redmond shannon reports women's
rights groups say they'll believe it
when they see it
barely 48 hours since they took control
and the taliban are suggesting they've
changed women will be afforded all their
rights
whether it is in work or other
activities because women
are a key part of society
and
we are guaranteeing all their rights
within the limits of islam what the
limits of islam amount to is something
they did not elaborate on during taliban
rule in the 90s girls over 10 could not
go to school women could not work or
leave the house alone and they had to
wear a burqa
perhaps one encouraging sign tuesday a
female news anchor interviewing a
taliban spokesperson
the dramatic scenes of mostly men at
kabul airport may indicate women are not
venturing outside there are reports of
female students and employees being sent
home women's images being whitewashed
away concern for the future of women and
girls won't be lessened by mere words
for me it honestly it doesn't make sense
to um to believe the taliban would
change their qualities towards women
towards children and their basic rights
even if i go somewhere else they i will
always have a target on my back pashtana
durani runs a girls education ngo and is
asking the world not to give up on
afghan women every canadian watching it
right now can do it by calling their
leaders to pressurize the taliban into
accepting educational rights for girls
that is general educational rights and
then at the same time for
working acts for afghan women durani has
gone into hiding for now but insists she
won't live in fear and wants to talk to
the taliban about the future of women in
her country
redmond shannon double news london
and that is global national for this
tuesday i'm robin gill tonight your
canada is commonwealth stadium in
edmonton thank you for watching have a
great night
[Music]
you